Alex Trebek sat down with Michael
Strahan for the primetime special what
is jeopardy and as he continues to
battle camp by us because with
pancreatic cancer
alex has considered what he will say
whenever he does choose to stop hosting
the long-running game show in the walk
off that stage and and and you're done
with Jeopardy what do you imagine it to
be like it will be a significant moment
for me but I've kind of in my mind
rehearsed it already and what I would do
on that day is tell the director time
the show down to leave me 30 seconds at
the end that's all I want and I will say
my goodbyes I will tell people don't ask
me who's going to replace me because I
have no say in that whatsoever but I'm
sure that if you give them the same love
and attention and respect that you have
shown me for the past 30 however many
years then they will be a success and
the show will continue being a success
and until we meet again god bless you
and goodbye
it's already thought through I don't
like ya hispano extra bad no not my
favorite game show Alex Trebek is like
the greatest show host and I'm not
surprised at all that you know who's
gonna say that's he's so professional
and everything I'm sure he's got a plan
yeah he's in no way announced that he's
gonna leave the show he's in no way said
that but imagine being him though in the
position where people are constantly
asking like it was gonna replace because
they've been you've been asking this for
years before even talk of him being sick
what's happening and he's like I'm
Pullman's yeah like I'm still doing this
thing yeah so he has all that to contend
with people thinking about who's gonna
come next bus obviously his being ill
and he's thinking I don't want to I
don't want to say I know what he's
thinking but it seems that he's got to
think a lot about endings right now yeah
right shel says such a sweet man Paula
says I would not have asked that
question of aw what a perfect that
response yeah Thomas says Alex is truly
a strong man and his used to show really
talk about the issue of cancer and God
bless him for his courage strength and
integrity and even beyond like his
cancer battle because I mean Pat Sajak
did interview week so he went through a
little bit health scare he's totally
fine but even he's saying probably in a
couple years I'm gonna retire yeah so
yeah it'll be interesting with both
those just like these huge iconic shows
they've been on for what 35 years yeah
so if both those hosts kind of leave
around the same what's gonna happen
like yeah is going strong like yeah drew
carey's would do that for what probably
close to 10 years now he's been doing it
so yeah I think those will alum will
live on but yeah I mean I don't even
like to think about that well it's true
like when you think about the shows the
person that's been hosting that show for
30-some odd years is such tied into the
identity of that show so strongly right
yeah yeah outstretched is such a classy
guy so keep on doing jeopardy Alex